I have a problem it's a severe problem
it's about as severe as my tie-dye
addiction but it's even more severe
because I don't want to go out with my
friends anymore
I don't want to play xbox I don't even
want to make youtube videos anymore all
I want to do is watch sleepy kitties on
YouTube that's all I want to do I wake
up in the morning guess what I do go to
youtube and I watch some sleepy kitties
it's time for lunch what am I gonna eat
for lunch I'm gonna have some sleepy
kitty please with the sight of sleepy
kitty oh what's that
it's time to go and hang out with my
friend just watch it doesn't matter
because I have all the friends that I
need in their sleepy kitties they're
tired and they're sleepy they're so
freakin sleeping they're so sleepy that
I don't even get sleepy anymore do I
sleep nip that's because all I'm doing
is watching sleepy kitties on YouTube
and you know what happened the last time
that I actually touched a real cat let
me show you what happened that I'm
allergic I sneezed so much it broke a
blood vessel in my eye now I just watch
the sleepy kitties I wash them sleep i
watch them take their little siesta
i watch them take their little naps i
replay them over and over and over and
over again
you see that great do you want to see it
again perfect
siesta grande and if you don't know what
that means I'm pretty sure it means big
sleep or sleep big in Spanish it doesn't
matter because I don't speak Spanish the
only thing that I speak is sleepy kitty
let me demonstrate for you
oh really do you think they do it better
mm-hmm yeah sleepy do you need a little
nap what's your favorite sleepy kitty
video cuz you know you've got one or you
have a job oh you got fired for your job
for watching too many sleepy kitty
videos on YouTube I know I know I'm
right there with you okay bye I got some
sleepy kitties to watch